if you don't know who this is this is a
Giovanna and Toinette Oh
today's it are very lucky day because
the day she decided to shave her
mustache
later on tonight I ask you to be my
girlfriend
right I wouldn't go down guys so today I
am off to go to a go-for-broke meeting
yes now earlier this week I went to go
meet up Bart and Joe and it turns out
that these [ __ ] forgot what
time we're supposed to meet up at I
think these [ __ ] forgot about me so I
get there at 6 o'clock on the dot I text
Martin Joe and I'm like hey where you
guys at I'm at the office and then Bart
writes back we're about to eat we'll be
there around seven ish now in my mind
I'm like okay that's a little odd you
have me wait here for like an hour and a
half and then Bart right back so we
should eat and like 5:30 so we could be
there on time at 7:00 yep you
[ __ ] I hate your [ __ ] guts
son of a [ __ ] so now we are back to
getting go-for-broke
on point getting ready to go and launch
for you guys hopefully by the end of
this year and it's just gonna be the
[ __ ] I actually met Bart and Joe at the
San Diego Asian Film Festival roughly
about 40 years ago now prior to doing
the film festival I assume that I didn't
know who they were because you know when
people were mentioning them I literally
didn't know or I thought I didn't know
but it turns out I knew who they were
because they did this one video Korean a
History Channel that [ __ ] video ruins
my college experience cuz prior to that
video coming out nobody knew how to do a
Korean accent
it means a Chinese a zero but a Japanese
negative to me that is by far one of the
funniest videos that they ever did it
I'll talk to that I was sharing it with
my friends and family at Thanksgiving
one of the bigger reasons why I decide
to let Bart and Joe in with this is
because uh it's a very rare thing in my
personal opinion when you meet some
people that you instantly click with now
I remember both these fools when we met
in San Diego I told him about this place
called tapas El Gordo tacos el gordo is
my favorite taco joint of all time hands
down I was telling them that they were
the best tacos and then from being in LA
part was like being in his head this
[ __ ] don't know [ __ ] about [ __ ] taco
Sacramento living as mother [ __ ] this
bull bar and joe bit into that taco and
said me [ __ ] started crying on
the spot it was so delicious Mario had
become a huge part of my life and a big
part of my foundation out here in LA
they're probably one of the bigger
reasons why I continue to stay on
YouTube because originally I didn't even
want to be on this platform it wasn't
what I wanted I honestly felt that
YouTube was a space where everybody did
anything just to just to get a little
lion letter just to get popular that's
not what I wanted I had a specific goal
by the time I want
a huge data committee that I wanted to
create comedy that made people last and
I felt like YouTube was just a space
where people were just nabbing it
anything that they could take that'll
help them get popular and recognized and
I [ __ ] hate that [ __ ] because for me
what's the whole point of recognition
when you're doing nothing with your life
yeah people remember you for a moment
tickle call they shake your hands but if
you're not creating art that kind of
like progresses what's the whole point
but go-for-broke is one of my biggest
projects is gender I don't want you guys
to partake and share in this I mean I
know it yet it's a clothing brand but a
lot of the clothing brands that we wear
have to do with a lot of [ __ ] that we
don't represent now a lot of the times I
feel like for people like we tend to be
scared to reach out for more because
we're afraid of losing things that we
already have my personal opinion if you
want something in life you got to take
those chances you got to take those
risks and grab what is rightfully yours
now I guarantee you for me for about
20-some odd years of my life I wasn't
[ __ ] loser and what I mean by a loser
I don't mean like I was like out killing
people robbing people I was a criminal
what I met with a loser was I was just
living my life day to day without a
purpose and I lived a good a part of my
life letting everybody take the [ __ ]
that was meant for me and I was left
behind
go-for-broke times when you wear our
brand I want you to embody what it's
about reading toes no dang that's just a
a message help gain respect openers that
Captain Morgan does that rickety market
and good I'm sorry for hearing it oh I
just had one bag of spiked balls I would
explode it at your [ __ ] feet